je reçois maintenant roger planchon pour
le triomphe de l'amour au théâtre de
l'odéon
quarante ans après la seconde surprise
de l'amour planchon planches à nouveau
sur marivaux dans une mise en scène qui
marie libertinage et amour courtois mais
n'épouse pas le marivaudage bref
planches on ne badine pas avec l'amour
ou au soir donc vous êtes auteur vous
êtes acteur metteur en scène et cinéaste
les seniors un film j'espère qu'on aura
le temps d'en parler
et donc là on vous reçoit pour le
triomphe de l'amour donc à l'odéon
jusqu'au 26 avril qui était monté à
villeurbanne et puis après vous avez
fait votre si donc lautrec et puis là
maintenant vous le donner à l'odéon et
pendant ce temps là je vous posais la
question tout à l'heure c'est que
pendant ce temps il ya malgré tout un
spectacle à villeurbanne prix toujours
toujours d'accord
si je veux demander ce qui se passait à
villeurbanne alors on l'a dit en
commençant c'est un don juan non
seulement c'est le premier donjon
féminin en plus violemment aux
féministes n'ont violemment féministe
passe quand même à marivaux est avocat
il voyait très bien la situation des
bonnes femmes qui quand elle tombe
amoureuse et qu'elles ont beaucoup
d'argent mais si elle se marie c'est un
malheur puisqu'elle donne tout et
s'enfermer dans un placard il cueillait
encore il ya encore des millions de
femmes peut-être même des billards sur
cette terre connais ce soir là alors
l'histoire bon ça se passe dans la dent
en grèce on en grèce antique alors il ya
le 18e édition
oui quand même oui enfin le grès une
espèce de graisse revu et corrigé oui
alors leonid qui est jouée par isabelle
gélinas l'excellente isabelle gélinas
donc elle est sur un l et princesse elle
s'aperçoit que le trône a été en fait
usurper pas par son oncle un jour elle
découvre je le fais vita comme ça elle
découvre l'héritier légitime et elle se
déguise en homme elle devient faux sion
pour se rapprocher de l'héritier
légitime qui et agissent et agissent et
réfugié chez un philosophe s'appelle
armes aux 4 qui jouait par vous on y
reviendra et qui a une soeur léontine et
les séduit tous les deux voies la
province va arrêter de la chine vis tout
le monde elle s'était tout le monde va
lancer c'est un peu comme dans le
bouquin tina dont on va parler demain
sera coté théorème un peu ça c'est à
dire un peu film de pasolini
il ya deux cents ans ce sens oui c'est
ça c'est très cruel même temps oui alors
d'un côté il ya le libertinage le plus
lu plus totale quoi le libertinage qui a
inspiré sa de la clau il était très bon
lecteur de marivaux oui c'est à dire
mario était pas du tout aimé ses
contemporains mais je savais le lire oui
et donc ils ont pris dans marivaux
l'essentiel lors beaucoup et vous dit
enfin que cette tradition libertines va
jusqu'à roger vailland aragon solaire
c'est que finalement c'est le sida qu'il
ya un peu ça calme un peu les ardeurs à
calmer les ardeurs et d'un autre côté on
va repartir oui
de notre côté il ya l'amour fou l'amour
absolu qui est un petit peu que ça ça
n'a aucun rapport avec le 18e c'est à
dire que maryvonne une façon folle dans
la même pièce mais l'amour courtois
chevaleresque au sens où dante et
pouvait aimer mais les deux alors passé
le thème c'est l'amour un amour passion
l'amour raison l'amont les gradins donc
ça intéresse tout le monde en fait tout
le monde sait qu'on ne gère pas la même
voilà six parcs ruelles si l'histoire
très mais tout le monde peut se
retrouver là dedans je veux dire c'est
déjà en rit du début à la voilà elle est
très calme et puis c'est bourré en plus
alors marivaux a été le premier à parler
de tout ça d'une certaine façon parce
que bon c'est tellement c'est un sacré
mais ce qui est curieux c'est que les
contemporains ne le voit pas voir les
voltaire pense qu'il est lui l'héritier
de racine alors que il pique que le côté
pompe des tragédies et c'est évidemment
marivaux qui sait lire racines et qu'il
veut mais l'abbé rider la pièce est
assez est assez dure comme vous dites et
la lra signal on pourrait dire d'une
certaine façon et ça c'est quelque chose
que vous alors roger planchon vous avez
mis en exergue
on vous aviez monté il ya 40 ans la
seconde surprise de l'amour c'est pas
fière d'y aménager à juste après
jurassic park voilà il y avait une
polémique parce que vous aviez monter ça
en refusant le en refusant dix ans le
badinage et en mettant l'accent sur le
manche on sait s'il y avait une
polémique à ce moment là parce que les
gens voyaient maryse avait fait un
énorme scandale fait un énorme scandale
à l'époque tout simplement parce que
j'avais fait une chose très simple si
vous les dents marivaux les personnages
manquent tout le temps uniquement ses
des espèces des preuves qui font passer
à ce kit en phase donc pour la première
fois il y avait des très bon menteur qui
parlait avec un fond de vérité
c'était pas des menteurs maladroit
c'était des vrais menteur et on a alors
brusquement la cruauté de la pièce
remonte voilà et on a compris à ce
moment là qu'en fait fallait pas
confondre marivaux et marivaudages
c'est ce que vous avez mis en valeur
parce que marivaux il ya la trahison il
ya la tromperie la manipulation enfin
comment disait sais c'est dur
vous vous aimez pas quand on quand on
montre vous dites moi je crois que plus
on monte des sentiments dégueulasse plus
on s'approche de la vérité est en fait
vous avez vous êtes vous êtes disons un
fidèle à marivaux quand vous dites il
faut être un peu trop bon pour les
tracés quoi oui j'aime les auteurs qui
sont plutôt bons
puis je trouve qu'il ya trop de
complaisance actuellement sur le
discours cynique il y avait avant des
films il y avait avant des bouquins on
disait tout le monde était bon tout le
monde entier maintenant c'est presque le
contraire est ce que c'est dégueulasse
voilà plus on approche de la vérité
c'est pas vrai oui on approche fois plus
de la vérité avec les deux glaces diable
c'est une idée neuve alors le casting
bon ben on l'a dit jean et isabelle
gélinas bien il ya un groupe de jeunes
acteurs formidables il ya régis royer
qui joue dans le film l'autre est qu'il
y a micha lescot qui est un grand acteur
de 23 ans et vous verrez que c'est un
très grand acteur
il y à alain payen il y a et à vous
alors vous vous dites je suis un peu le
bouche-trou de ma troupe quoi séduire là
vous avez demandé à sami frey à
gradignan interdit aux personnes étaient
libres vous aviez de collecte c'est
simple vous aviez déjà remplacé le
brasseur dans georges dandin non plus un
jour il se foulent le pied alors
vraiment du talent alors votre vie c'est
très étonnant parce qu'en fait vous vous
dites volontiers quand vous étiez petit
votre père y poser des rails de tramway
et votre mère elle bossait chez un
charcutier vous gardiez les vaches et
vous étiez dans le maquis à l'âge de
l'âge de 12 ans non mais réparer plus à
une époque
oui mais enfin vous étiez gamin j'ai
quand même eu la croix vous avez quand
même la croix de guerre à à 12 ans et
demi je dire tu es à l'époque où on voit
plutôt du pape ont depuis six mois on
est content 30 petits région qu'est la
croix de guerre pour faits de résistance
quand même non ça fait plaisir
non ce que je veux dire c'est comment
vous avez la révélation en fait du du
spectacle ces fonds peut raconter
l'histoire parce qu'elle est belle vous
étiez chez les pères allez vous faisiez
le mur pour aller voir chez les frères
etienne qu'on appelait les frères à
quatre bras parce qu'ils avaient des
banques bizarre on finit pas donc oui
j'étais
j'avais pas à l'école je suis jamais
l'école et je faisais le mur tous les
jours et un jour
surveillant un type très bien m'a pris à
la fin du mahdi août était cet après
midi gymnastique
non c'était au cinéma qu'est ce que tu
as vu dans le film il dit écoute très
mauvais goût il faut que tu ailles voir
il ya un très bon film citizen kane et
c'est vrai je l' ai tellement raconté
que je suis à dire mais c'est vrai qu'il
a changé ma vie mais bien sûr c'est très
important
on vous l'avait vu comme cette fois un
citizen kane sept jours de suite
oui cette journée vous n'étiez pas
facile mais je venais quand même le
metteur en scène cowboys
ben ouais c'est ça regardez les vastes
non mais c'est fou donc vous l'avez vu
cette fois puis après vous ai dit je
vais rentrer dans le spectacle c'est
quand même insensé c'est le une sorte de
chemin de damas resort d'un seul coup
vous êtes ibiza se ressemblent et vous
vous lancez dans trois ans et vous
devenez j'ai même fait du théâtre parce
que wells avait une troupe de théâtre
oui oui qu'est venue au théâtre par le
cinéma quand même quand même rare
général c'est souvent la verte vous
dites souvent aussi jeté un petit voyou
j'ai été sauvé par le cinéma petit voyou
pourquoi beau nom mais on avait des
mauvais côtés son mari dieu dit des
choses coach a jugé tout à fait
absolument à châteauroux vous avez vous
êtes sauvés de ça et vous avez rencontré
artaud et vous en êtes
je suis passé directement de du fond de
l'ardèche si vous voulez un milieu
intellectuel paris où il y avait à damas
il ya vait marthe robert y avait des
gens comme ça et tous les amis d'artaud
oui donc c'était un milieu tout à fait
le contraire de ce que je connaissais
c'était l'époque des temps modernes où
tu faisais beaucoup fréquenté à l'époque
sa retraite tout ça c'est quand même
incroyable que murray comme destin et
après alors bon la carrière va pas faire
tout votre carrière parce que sinon il
sera content j'ai fait tellement de
choses
enfin c'est vrai qu'à un moment vous
avez pris le maquis si vous êtes parti à
villeurbanne quoi c'est une autre façon
de temps que j'ai toujours été j'ai
toujours été attaché à deux choses je
voulais j'ai toujours été partisan de la
décentralisation
donc j'ai jamais quittée en vérité
vélomanes j'ai jamais bougé on m'a
proposé plusieurs fois la
comédie-française l'odéon chaillot et
c'est dans la ville et j'ai toujours dit
non non je suis attaché c'est comme une
scène qui lui robert hossein qui lui est
vraiment parti à reims vous étiez resté
dans le car c'est là-bas mois à 11 ans
j'étais amoureux d'une petite danseuse
du tas de villeurbanne j'y suis resté
dites moi alors c'était charles hernu le
maire de villeurbanne
vous étiez au courant vous de ces
histoires là qu'il était un peu et vous
verrez ce que vous connaissez la jolie
histoire de remuer
peut-être qu'elle va vous amuser le jour
qu'à quinze jours trois semaines avant
que les histoires commencent je fais une
espèce de présentation d'une pièce de
shakespeare et en était là ils étaient
venus voir la présentation était assez
sympa et je parle de shakespeare et du
pouvoir comme ça et puis arrive toutes
les histoires que vous connaissez le
jour où il est viré et quitte le
gouvernement
et il vient seul le soir au théâtre j'y
suis à peu près seul ce soir là il dit
fois il faudrait vous me parlez un tout
petit peu de shakespeare et de pouvoir s
qui raccorde exactement l'histoire est
vraie c'est ça va pas changer vos
relations avec lui n'allez pas vous en
doutiez pas là dans toutes les années
alors il ya une chose comme qui vous a
un peu déçu ce tir que bon le tnp ça
vire théâtre national populaire est en
fait bon populaire certes mais que
malgré tout il ya un plafond vous dire
qu'on peut pas il ya des gens qui vont
au théâtre ya beaucoup de gens qui vont
dans votre théâtre mais que malgré tout
le théâtre peut pas être aussi populaire
qu'on l'entendait disons le sans dents
mais il n'y a même plus le cinéma n'est
même plus voyons maintenant que c'est la
télé populaire ça bouge le théâtre a été
populaire après ça a été le cinéma et
maintenant c'est raté et peut-être
demain c'est autre chose
alors vous
engager totalement dans le théâtre
puisque vous prenait jamais de vacances
il ya une anecdote qui s'élève sur vous
c'est que le jour de votre mariage vous
avez retardé la répétition d'une heure
pour vous marier c'est comme ça oui
jamais été autre de père de famille en
plus parce que ça oui c'est ça et vous
les prenez jeunes parler dans lequel 24
ans et elle est alors vous avez dit les
grands théâtres doivent prendre en main
leur dette leur destin audiovisuel si je
pense qu'il faut que le théâtre se
transforme enfin lancer dans la bataille
quand il essaye de mener si voulez je
pense que quelques grands et il faudrait
changer un peu les choses dans le
théâtre moi je pense que il devrait
exister des centres de création d'un
véritable centre de création qui face à
la fois du spectacle vivant et des
spectacles audiovisuels que ce soient
des films ou des télés et puis cette
dichotomie
oui parce que tous les acteurs le
souhaite en réalité c'est très curieux
je suis pas le seul d'ailleurs à le dire
simplement évidemment unités comme ça ça
marche quand il y à un politique
important qui dit on peut peut-être
essayer ça faudrait andré malraux pour
faire ça il faudrait jacques sa grande
époque non des fois quelqu'un peut le
faire aussi
on vous le souhaite alors vous avez donc
évidemment vous êtes acteur et vous êtes
réalisateur est réalisée jusqu'à
aujourd'hui trois films khwaja dandin
pas georges dandin dandin louis enfant
roi et lautrec alors qu'entre sûr qu'en
septembre 71% viendrait alors oui oui
avec non mais vraiment parce que l'art
vous ça doit être
qu'est-ce que pourquoi ne pouvait
lautrec je veux dire pourquoi quelque
dix minutes avant de choisir lautrec je
sais franchement d'accord mais bon j'ai
toujours admiré ce peintre et maintient
précisément c'est un homme bon qui a un
humour fabuleux c'est un jeune type
lautrec
c'est quelqu'un qui meurt à l'âge de
mozart et les gens ne savent pas très
bien tout ça oui c'est vrai le village
une espèce de légende autour de lui donc
c'était amusant de faire un film
vous avez arrêté le avec la même troupe
s'est fait l'auteur mais maintenant il
attend ils font marivaux alors vous vous
êtes autodidacte et vous vous êtes
énormément intéressé à l'histoire devant
quelque chose qui vous a ébloui et
habité et vous dites le 20e siècle est
une catastrophe ambiante parce que
finalement eagle s'adonner l'état
prussien nietzsche le nazisme enfin
jusqu'à turin et marx le stalinisme
regarder le ciel
non je pense très barbare mais on va
maintenant tout le monde le dit ouais
tout le monde l'a dit et même
l'intégrisme par dessus on constate en
pillant est ce que vous pensez pas que
c'est parce que c'est le premier siècle
de l'homme sans dieu non c'est vrai save
dieu s'étant éloignés comme dirait
l'autre
ben oui ça provoque quelque chose en
gros si vous voulez d'ailleurs on va le
cynisme d'hitler a gagné à peu près
d'être ouais ce qui vous fait le plus
peur maintenant c'est le signe
finalement ce que vous disiez sur le oui
je pense que je pense que c'est parlant
quand les gens disent y'a trop de
violence au cinéma je dis c'est pas les
coups de pistolet parce que les gamins
ils savent très bien que c'est de la
chorégraphie oui la fin c'est comme une
danse mais tandis que ce qui est diffusé
dans les têtes par les dialogues doit
commencer autre chose oui ça va
directement dans directement directement
dans la tête oui il servait dans la tête
et après on se ressert bon méchoui c'est
fini ça y est ça passe d'être un quart
d'heure suis désolé je reçois maintenant
georges wolinski pour la parution chez
albin michel de monsieur paul à cuba le
roman dessiné des aventures politiques
exotiques d'un petit fonctionnaire à
moustache façon réac que la baie des
cochons transforme en bourse aux
concubins d'une cubaine bonsoir georges
s'annonce ne sais pas si vous avez
d'accord sur la définition avant de mon
oeuvre qui quand même un roman d'une
grande envolée un vrai roman lui c'est
un vrai roman pour ça vraiment je montre
à la caméra c'est ce qu'il faut dire
c'est que c'est un genre nouveau c'est
un roman dessiné voit la couverture on
fait comme à la télé on montre et puis
voilà l'intérieur ça c'est règles je
sais pas pourquoi je suis tombé sur
cette page
il n'y a pas déjà passé à chaque page
quand damas voilà voilà comment il ya le
copage correct voilà mesdames messieurs
il ya quelques pages correction bon
alors c'est est prépublié cet été dans
charlie hebdo
j'en avais un peu assez de faire ce que
je fais d'habitude des dialogues
donc j'ai commencé cette histoire et
comme je faisais déjà il ya longtemps
pro paulette je n'ai pas du tout écrit
le synopsis j'ai commencé à créer les
personnages une semaine et puis j'ai
attendu l'autre semaine genre j'ai
continué semaine par semaine sans jamais
savoir comment ça allait se terminer
comme un vrai feuilletoniste en fait
c'est à dire en gc inventant j'adore
travailler comme ça parce que je m'amuse
en mairie vent et puis il ya un moment
où les personnages font un peu ce qu'ils
veulent
j'ai plus qu'à les regarder mais c'est
très bon alors c'est l'histoire d'un
petit fonctionnaire étriqué qui bosse à
la mairie de paris alors évidemment il
connaît madame à l'office déjà là j'ai
utilisé ma culture journal de
journalistes de l'actualité
il connaît tout le monde il sait comment
on peut arranger il est l'homme à tout
faire et il est aux besoins tout et
c'est un homme discret sur dans lequel
on peut avoir confiance qui n'a pas de
vie amoureuse et sexuelle
il est puceau les puceaux et quand ils
arrivent à cuba dont il part à cuba
c'est ses rapports avec les autres sont
bouleversés parce qu'ils découvrent les
femmes découvrent la musique y découvre
la magie
voilà il a la révélation quoi il devient
un frère un saint il le pratique là la
religion de la santé riz à la religion
afro cubaine et il devient complètement
un autre m'a tellement pas ça dure une
semaine sont vrais et il est obligé en
revenant de se mettre des lunettes de
soleil puisque son regard a changé sa
démarche a changé et puis en plus il est
devenu un [ __ ] ah oui c'est à dire
qu'il ya un énorme sexe ce qui fait bien
plaisir à nos amis cubaine non mais
c'est vrai c'est lui savait même pas ils
savaient pas ce qu'ils avaient entre les
jambes en fait mais là quand il découvre
ça il veut en profite après moi j'ai mis
tous les centres moi j'aurais rêvé
d'avoir un énorme c'est bien sûr et
parce que tout le monde dit que c'est
pas important la taille ça aurait changé
ma vie enfin bon alors cuba apparaît
quand même un peu dans ce bouquin vais
moi rire la cub apparaît un peu dans ce
bouquin comme un un un lupanar c'est à
dire est ce qu'aujourd'hui finalement
les les
les gens comme vous et d'autres vont pas
à cuba un peu comme d'autres vont à
bangkok où elle manie est-ce que c'est
pas devenu un peu le pas des gens comme
moi en tout cas les gens comme vous je
suis allé à cuba la première fois en 70
et j'y allais pour des raisons de parce
que ça me plaisait que cette révolution
plaisir que ce peuple me plaisait je n'y
avait pas de cette prostitution qui
convoie actuelle marquis apparente faut
pas vous exagérez quand même quand vous
dites que ça paraît comme un lupanar
c'est la première impression mais
évidemment si vous allez à la havane
dans les grandes villes comme saint
thiébaut des coupes mais si vous allez
dans les petits villages comme ça
antonio de los manos là vous avez
affaire une population dévoué et vivant
modestement avec des enfants qui sont à
l'école jusqu'à 4h30 en uniforme
il faut à côté de du cloaque et
l'amérique latine cuba mais je doute un
pays assez les gens sont quand même et
c'est autre chose
alors toute façon vous êtes assez
élogieux avec cuba malgré tout parce que
vous dites je vais lire la quatrième de
couverture
l'amitié le rhum la dignité les cigares
la beauté l'amour la musique la fois la
danse le courage le seul pays d'amérique
latine
alors attention le seul pays d'amérique
latine où les enfants sont moins
nombreux que les profs les médecins plus
nombreux que les malades les délinquants
moins nombreux que les flics et où il y
a plus d'analphabètes parmi les
touristes que parmi les habitants je ne
doute pas que ce soit vrai mais c'est un
peu la géographie quand même pour cuba
c'est un peu baba coûte si on ne peut
pas dire du bien des amis rien on ne
parlait pas des prisonniers politiques
par exemple c'est pas le propos du livre
le point n'a pas tellement que ça votre
ami delfeil de ton senmya boudé le fait
de temps ce oui bien sûr oui enfin je
mets à part par le free jazz est
d'accord sur beaucoup de choses
votre ami delfeil de ton disait dans le
nouvel observateur contre vous
d'ailleurs misé castro a été réélu pour
cinq ans à l'unanimité par les députés
élus à l'unanimité et tous les candidats
étaient des candidats uniques sur des
listes uniques et dans la presse
occidentale la seule chose qu'on a
retenu de ça c'est que castro a parlé
7h30 s'en aller pisser on n'a jamais
parlé de ce dont parle d'elle feuille de
temps il ya cuba c'est comme une
dictature georges on peut pas en parler
aussi
j'ai une indulgence
c'est bien de reconnaître parce que
c'est absolument parce que il ya eu
c'était presque une réussite et il ya
quelque chose de beau qui sort de tout
ça on peut on peut penser ce qu'on veut
de moi même je reste quand même un ami
de ces gens là mais vous de façon vous
avez toute façon donc vous pouvez dire
ce que vous voulez vous allen a priori
favorable enfin chez moi et chez
beaucoup de gens mais est-ce que vous
n'êtes pas le même sentiment
sérieusement que vous risquer d'encourir
les mêmes critiques que celles qui vous
ont assailli quand vous en 79 zettel et
en urss où naît de ce voyage ça fait un
scandale
vous allez en urss
vous étiez pas fait pas spécialement
gêné par les gens qui étaient au goulag
est ce qu'aujourd'hui finalement on peut
pas vous reprocher de ne pas pu savoir
d'intérêt pour les prisonniers
politiques de cuba que pour les gens qui
étaient au goulag en 79
je peux changer je m'en fous ouais mais
le goulag à l'époque zi est ce vraiment
important qua non j'ai pas dit ça ouais
je voulais je dis ce que vous avez dit à
l'époque je l'avais les juifs on vous
disait les juifs ils les vire du rsv les
juifs ils les vieillir en urss ils ont
bien raison puisqu'ils sont pas contents
ils peuvent pas ben ben j'avais raison
oui bon enfin on peut pas à la fois si
vous voulez passer six mois à juger
papon et en même temps accepter que les
bouquets brejnev vire les russes du rss
si l'on peut pas faire deux poids et
deux mesures
bon ce que je disais c'est que les gens
vivaient pas si mal que ça
là-bas que moi quand j'étais jeune je
vivais plus mal qu'un camp russe oui oui
la france dans les années 50
faut voir comment vous vivez sur
l'afghanistan par exemple vous dit je
suis la situation je la déplore mais je
la condamne pas qua non à l'époque ça
derrière j'ai eu raison
on a vu le bordel de saigner avant il
valait mieux que ce soient les russes
qui l'a béni oui oui vous dites que
l'ouzbékistan c'est mieux que
l'afghanistan vous disiez à l'époque et
qu'il aurait fallu être ouzbek cardon
non mais vous avez le mérite de le tenir
opposition non mais par exemple pour
venir à cuba
par exemple dans les années 50 quand on
est en vacances en espagne on vous
disait ne va pas en vacances chez franco
syndic tata après quand on est en
vacances en grèce on vous disait vas pas
en vacances chez les colonels pataky le
fait d'elle en vacances chez castres où
c'est un peu la même chose finalement
ces indicateurs tout ça si les gens ils
vont si les gens veulent aller se dorer
le curé valade héros faire envoyer des
voyages touristiques moi je vivais parce
qu'il ya des dessinateurs il ya une
ambiance qui me plaît chez je fais un
travail humanitaire là bas aussi lille
me plaît mais tous ne me plaît pas tout
me plaît pas dans ce livre je dis tout
ce qui m'a eue les passionés tout n'est
pas il faut bien dire c'est pas du sang
20% les étriers fixes et dans les frites
et yahia qui est un dessinateur espagnol
qui est une chose formidable il a dit un
ami c'est quelqu'un dit qui dit du mal
de toi devant toi moi je dis enfin quand
j'y vais j'ai dit mais qu'est ce que
c'est ça et pourquoi ça a changé
alors ils essayent de m'expliquer j'ai
dit comment ce cas pourquoi vous
acceptez de cette prostitution alors le
ministre que j'en fasse ou le deep in
dit elle sont majeurs et font ce
qu'elles veulent parce que
oui puis c'est la sexualité là bas c'est
pas pareil tout à fait que chez nous à
14 15 ans elles sont mères la plupart
sont r&d jason un enfant donc au canada
non à 18 ans donc ça veut dire qu'ils
auraient des totalitarismes qui serait
plus acceptable que d'autres et 60 ans
sur une route de totalitarisme cuba je
le sens pas comme ça moi ouais ouais
vous faites bien d'un côté castro et
l'autre côté le peuple et le peuple il
souffre bien quand même de cette
situation non il souffre pas du
totalitarisme cuba s'est passé à quillan
maire de plus il souffre parce qu'il n'a
pas de lait qu'il a pas de beurre et qui
n'a pas de prix qui apparaît à la manger
c'est surtout ça il souffre plus du
blocus qu de castro bon donc vous ne
changeait pas d'avis pas du tout vous
avez dit une fois je ne suis pas contre
l'ambiguïté j'envie donc on en est là
toujours toujours très bien merci
c'est à la prochaine voilà j'en rappelle
ne suis pas déçu ah non moi je vous
prends que vous êtes comme vous et cuba
monsieur paul à cuba wolinski donc un
roman dessiné excellent je vous
conseille c'est chez albin michel merci
beaucoup georges
à très bientôt faire des t-bonds soir je
autre chemise elle fait un petit mais
c'est parce que je voulais pas mettre ça
comme vous mon cher hardy cela que je
suis habillé en noir comme lorsque vous
laissez pas grave voit le biais pourquoi
en noir moi je vous dirai pourquoi
pour les mêmes raisons pouvant pas pour
pas montré que de temps en temps je
prends du bit voilà pour moi c'est pour
être sûres comme reconnaissent aussi ce
que vous n'êtes pas hors de prix le
chichi ça peut m'arriver ce qu'on vous
voit par donc vous triomphez dans les
villes enchaînement vous triomphez dans
on connaît la chanson on va pas en
parler
le film le fils triompher vous aussi
vous venez de tourner hasards et
coïncidences avec lelouch
oui je ne sais quoi l'histoire en deux
mots des gangsters des avocats n'ont pas
de dexter par l'avocat une femme trois
hommes y ont traversé la vie de cette
famille
ils auront chacun leur importance et
puis et puis voilà et puis à partir de
là le hasard et les coïncidences qui
n'existe pas comme tout le monde le sait
feront ce qu'ils ont à faire
alors vous êtes sur le comte de monte
cristo fait quel rôle j'ai fait le
procureur de villefort qui est donc cet
horrible personnage qui envoie deux
montes aubagne à edmond dantès bien se
venger vingt ans plus tard d'une manière
terrible intérêt très beau personnage
très noir très terrible mais paraît que
j'arrive même affaire que finalement
dans la compassion à la fin pour ce
personnage tellement il souffre alors et
vous êtes à partir du 16 janvier dans le
mari la femme et l'amant donc de sacha
guitry que vous avez déjà joué un petit
peu en province en suisse en belgique a
créé à lyon 4 des célestins et puis on
est allé à marseille on est allé à
bruxelles on est elle en suisse quelques
villes françaises et puis maintenant on
vient de jouer à paris alors j'ai pas vu
la pièce
j'irai là bas sinon je préfère vous le
dire raison de plus pour me pour me la
vendre il ya un guitry revival en ce
moment dans toscan du plantier produit
des films tirés de wye river oui et vous
pensez que c'est dû à quoi je sais
simplement que c'est dû au talent de
guitry qui comme toujours dans ces cas
là que ce soit guitry ou bernstein par
exemple quand elle a remis bernstein au
goût du jour il n'avait plus avec mélo
vous savez dans ces cas-là ce genre
d'auteurs qui ont été des auteurs à
grand succès des auteurs très publique
et des auteurs qu'on a qualifié ou de
pompiers ou de boulevardier qui aura été
auteur bien plus intéressant que ça on
était foutu à la poubelle par une
intelligente et un circuit comme
d'habitude à tourner un peu vite le dos
à ce qu'écrivait ces gens là et on se
découvre aujourd'hui que évidemment ces
gens là ont des choses à dire qu'elles
soient légères ou moins légère en tout
cas il le disait avec talent et donc on
re découvre avec plaisir ce talent dans
l'histoire c'est quoi l'histoire n'y a
pas d'histoire oui il ya une morale
immoral
yako font la morale immoral de guitry
c'est que ladite l'adultère est le
premier sauveur du couple et puis si on
veut avoir un couple qui se porte bien
il faut avoir un amant dans la sphère
sinon on s'ennuie alors évidemment c'est
à la fois formidablement l'insolence et
délicieusement iconoclaste et en même
temps c'est une espèce de deux verres de
de santé et de bonheur délicieux vous
faites là mans bah oui je fais l'amour
votre compagne vinh bouix la faf et la
femme et le réalisateur enfin le metteur
en scène bernard murat
c'est le fait le mari oui et les bilans
c'est assez rigolo parce que vous êtes
l'amant de votre femme est mon meilleur
ami avec cette femme c'est la pnc très
geek rim en plus ce qui est drôle c'est
que vous vous dites souvent dans vos
interviews que vous essayez de vous
comporter avec evelyne bouix un peu
comme un amant c'est vous donner des
rendez-vous vous avez acheté un portable
pour vous téléphonez donc c'est assez
rigolo finalement non finalement le
la réalité plus forte que la fiction non
mais ce qui est ce qui est joli
dans cette histoire que c'est au fond
c'est une aventure d'amis je suis très
très depuis très longtemps ami avec
bernard murat je suis très longtemps
puisque admis avec evelyne bouix et le
fait de cette rencontre à trois est une
sorte de retrouvailles et artistique et
sentimental et habiter en tout cas
tourné à vous devez être heureux tous
les trois la fusée manif à saluer le
spectacle à un succès énorme
donc j'espère qu'il va avoir le même
succès ici à paris les gens parlent un
plaisir délicieuse qu'on imaginait bien
mais même très au delà de ce qu'on avait
pu imaginer car comme toujours on est
moins intelligent que l'auteur
intelligent l'auteur a écrit des choses
formidables qu'on n'avait même pas vu
aux répétitions aucune coupe public lui
a valu immédiatement
donc ça c'est c'est délicieux edmonde
charles roux qui est venu voir le
spectacle à marseille qui est remonté
qui adorait ça alice formidable plus
aucun d'entre nous ne serait capable
d'écrire comme ça aujourd'hui et c'est
absolument vrai parce que c'est moi je
veux bien qu'on traite ça de boulevard
si on veut ça m'est complètement égal ou
table bourgeois d'une façon il n'ya que
du théâtre bourgeois je connais ma peau
qu'est patate bourgeois faut faire la
révolution la fuente nous emmerder avec
cette terminologie là c'est intéressant
en tout cas populaire et sublimement
écrit c'est une langue très très peu de
gens aujourd'hui serait capable d'avouer
a tous envie d'aller le voir je vous
rassure je trouve ça faire un tabac à
paris aussi c'est votre votre première
enfin ça pourrai pas vous êtes sur scène
avec une rixe et la deuxième la deuxième
fois vous ai pas peur de terminer en
faire mais c'est pas méchant mais un peu
comme renaud barrault où aller comment
simone valère et jean desailly ou un jeu
stone et charden là tout le temps sans
manger d'abord stone charden e renaud
barrault desailly-valère wes a pas trop
de rapport
sinon huster qui joue juste et réaliste
et coûtait pas désagréable non jeu pas
comme ça dans la journée à une personne
non parce que si vous voulez on est
toute la journée pour faire autre chose
ensemble pour faire autre chose que pour
payer des notes de gaz pour caler au
cabinet oui c'est vrai donc on vit dans
un univers et pas celui de la réalité
un univers poétique donc je vois pas
comment on pourrait mieux partagé sa vie
que de cette manière là et puis ensuite
on est quand même loin du compte
renaud barrault ont passé 60 ans
ensemble et d'une manière admirable
j'espère que je passerai aussi longtemps
de ça avec avec avec evelyne mais enfin
on est quand même très autonome et
l'étagé ce qu'on fait c'est pareil si ça
te prend longtemps vous habitiez pas
ensemble on a on l'a on s'est
apprivoisés mutuellement
voilà alors vous avez l'habitude dans
tous les cas souvent vous donnez votre
avis comme ça sur des sujets autres que
votre métier vous dites quand un artiste
parle de politique c'est possible ce qui
est déjà plus difficile c'est quand un
même politique parle d'art donc vous
êtes souvent autorisés à vous exprimer
sur ce sujet je dis que c'est moins
grave pour un acteur de faire de la
politique que pour un homme politique de
jouer la comédie
on écrit dans le monde un papier 395 en
disant je demande à la gauche de
redevenir la gauche un grand papier
est-ce que vous aujourd'hui alors en
deux mots est ce que vous pensez que ça
va ou ne va pas je sais pas ah ben je
pense que en tout cas c'est sur la bonne
voie je vous attendais parce que vous
disent au contraire mais je ne suis pas
du tout un béni oui oui je veux dire que
ce que j'aime c'est jospin c'est qui
fait pas de la communication mais il
fait de la politique qu'on voit peu dans
les médias on y travaille que les gens
qui sont autour de lui travaille
également que jusqu'à preuve du
contraire ce qu'il dit il le fait où il
tente de le faire avec bonne foi
d'ailleurs majorité des gens le
reconnaissent
après on verra bien les résultats seront
là nous serons pas là on souhaite tous
qui seront là mais si vous voulez je
trouve que hilare toucher du doigt ce
que moi en tout cas
j'imaginais que de la gauche
c'est-à-dire hillary identifier le
discours de la gauche ça va les lois
pasqua les 35 heures oui on peut
discuter sur les lois pasqua c'est vrai
qu'on les approche pas en même temps
c'est plus compliqué que ça en a l'air
tout ça il ya pas déçu quoi pour le
moment ça va je ne suis pas déçu je
pense qu'il faut aller plus loin mais je
ne suis pas déçu je pense que cet homme
est un homme droit il ya une vraie
rectitude de penser et d'actes ça me va
parfaitement
alors vous êtes souvent au point des
positions disons un peu moraliste des
fois même de moralisateur est-ce que
vous n'êtes pas le sentiment je vais un
peu
c'est pas d'agressivité à mais quand
même des fois d'enfoncer des portes
ouvertes ce que vous dites par exemple
mois la valeur numéro un pour moi c'est
la tolérance qui oserait dire le
contraire jeudi a eu des tas de gens
d'états d'âme en mai de tas de gens des
tas de gens ne le disent pas mais le
fond oui si vous voyez ce que je veux de
dubaï l'un des endroits où la tolérance
est est un voeu pieux et largement
disparu de la circulation il ya des tas
de gens pour lesquels la tolérance n'est
pas une valeur fondamentale
il ya des tas de gens qui ne tolère pas
l'autre les autres ou ce que font les
autres
excusez moi que je veux dire que j'ai
pas l'impression de vous indigner
finalement sur des sujets où poumon est
à peu près d'accord non moi je crois pas
que tout le monde est à peu près
d'accord je suis pas pour les consensus
où je suis tout à fait prêt à
reconnaître à des gens qui ne sont pas
de mon bord que c'était quelqu'un m'en
donne et ils ont raison contre ce que je
peux penser moi et dans ces cas là je
suis le premier à m'incliner je suis
tout à fait capable de changer d'avis
quand l'autre à raison face de moi même
si je partage mon bord je suis tout à
fait la chorale j'ai simplement votre
compagne evelyne bouix disait en parlant
de votre attitude dans la vie elle
disait finalement pierre c'est un peu
comme condorcet jeu est ce que vous
venez de dire mais je me battrai à mort
pour jusqu'à la mort pour que vous
puissiez le dire et vous vous dites dans
une autre interview
la démocratie ne peut tolérer ce qui ne
la tolère pas ce qui revient à dire un
peu pas de liberté pour les ennemis de
la liberté
alors là justement nous y voilà enracine
peut tolérer que ce qu'il a tout l'air
d'un jeune en question est profondément
la démocratie et poté l'airé énormément
de choses énormément
condor c'est à dire je partage pas vous
avez votre avis mais je suis prêt à
mourir pour puissiez vous exprimer ou au
contraire pas de liberté pour les
ennemis de la liberté faut interdire le
front national par exemple puisque c'est
un sujet qui occupe beaucoup les débats
en ce moment écoutez c'est vrai que si
vous me demandez de réagir comme ça
viscéralement j'aurais bien envie de
dire qu'après tout il faut interdire le
front national évidemment j'aurais tort
de le dire
d'abord parce que ce parti et ceux qui
le dirigent s'appuie sur une situation
économique et sociale extrêmement
difficile qui est mondiale mais qui est
spécifiquement difficile en france et
que tous les gens qui votent pour le
front national ne sont pas des gens
forcément condamnable sont des gens en
perd 10
donc c'est d'ailleurs en cela qu'on
demande à la gauche d'être de nouveau la
gauche c'est-à-dire de régler ces
problèmes là on sait très bien que si on
tord le cou aux problèmes du chômage de
front national n'aura plus rien sur quoi
repose et donc effectivement le problème
n'est pas d'interdire le front national
le problème est de tendre le cou aux
problèmes sur laquelle il s'appuie pour
dresser les gens les uns contre les
autres c'est à dire l'air la haine de
l'autre l'exclusion le le le bouc
émissaire de l'immigré ou de celui qui
n'est pas comme vous qui ne parlent pas
la même langue et chivu volerait
parait-il votre travail mais si on ne
rompt au foot est dehors tous les
immigrés de france mais l'économie
française ce serait ce serait un
véritable désastre parce que les
immigrés nous sommes en france qu'ils
consomment
non mais je j'y reviens donc par rapport
au front national par exemple donc l
attitude qui est l'attitude de dire je
partage pas vos idées mais vous pouvez
exprimer
ou alors je pas liberté vos amis de la
liberté vous êtes sur les partisans que
le front national puisse s'exprimer
normalement au contraire qu'ils
s'expriment plus que plus que librement
et quand il s'exprime on peut pas dire
qu'il le fasse dans la dentelle
alors il est inutile ou de vous dire que
moi personnellement je préférerais ne
pas entendre ce genre de propos mais en
même temps la diabolisation
c'est une chose qui finira par se
retourner contre les gens qui ne règle
pas les problèmes la seule manière de
faire taire ce discours c'est de régler
les problèmes de la nation c'était réglé
le problème numéro 1 en france qui n'est
pas le problème de l'immigration
mais le problème du chômage est ce qu'il
est réglable vous me demandez ça moi si
ça va vous trouver les jeunes aillent
voir à lionel jospin des gens du
gouvernement
quand j'ai une bonne solution au
problème je dire qu' en france vous
savez très bien en allemagne c'est parti
c'est probablement extrêmement complexe
la question qu'on peut se poser que
viviane forrester et le pose dans son
livre très controversé comprend pourquoi
il est très controversé parce que ce
livre vu des choses terribles c'est que
peut-être aujourd'hui il ya toute une
catégorie de gens dont on n'a plus
besoin et auxquels on n'ose pas dire
qu'on a plus besoin d'eux et ça c'est
une horreur alors on peut se poser la
question qu'est ce qu'on fait ces gens
là on les parque on aimait dans des
camps de concentration ont des gaz
angels à l'époque contrairement à ce
qu'on pourrait croire faire un parterre
détails qu'est-ce qu'on fait ces gens là
aujourd'hui il occupe des assedic parce
qu'ils en ont marre de ne pas être
d'être coupable de ne pas travailler ils
veulent travailler ils ne peuvent pas
travailler
qu'est-ce qu'on en fait si on n'en fait
rien a effectivement faut les payer pour
nom les est bien raisonnable
concept qu'on les a occupés il étudiait
nationaux et des hug
aujourd'hui on arrive à l'instruire les
occuper le problème est extrêmement
complexe est facile de dire qu'on
pourrait arriver ça comme ça comme ça
ils accueillent la cahc ya sûrement pas
qu'à mai mais c'est le problème de faux
dernier point quand ça vous touche
personnellement c'est à dire par exemple
un moment il ya eu un problème de texte
étranger au rond point des champs
elysées où vous avez déclaré ben moi je
suis contre le fait qu'on joue des
textes étrangers dans cet extrait vous
avez dit à ce moment-là si c est trop
faible alors je suis xénophobe
vous avez déclaré oui ça devait pas être
aussi simple que ça mais je vois à quoi
vous faites allusion
c'est à dire quand ça vous touche
finalement la la la nous voulons c'est
pas ça non c'est pas ça c'est que
simplement je veux dire que à une
certaine époque on a transformé pour
l'apa transformer on appris le tape dur
au point et on a cueilli un certain
nombre de troupes étrangères qu'on a
parfaitement bien fait d'accueillir pour
seulement il y avait déjà le théâtre de
l'europe
alors peut-être aurait-on pu comment
dire prolonger l'héritage barreau
renault dans une digne comme celle-là
crée aussi un certain nombre d'auteurs
français contemporains vivants qu'on
joue peu ou pas du tout bon et puis il
ya d'autres théâtres
encore une fois comme l'odéon par
exemple ou 1 500 centres dont c'est la
vocation d'un qu'obligé de 2,2 de
prendre les salles d'être derrière les
autres pour ne pas non plus créer des
auteurs français y'a pas de xénophobie
du tout là dedans je suis l'honneur de
la france est d'accueillir les cultures
du monde entier
la france est probalement le pays qui
avec de plus c'est clair et net
elle accueille des cultures du monde
entier que ce soit le cinéma le théâtre
la mode la peinture le les arts de la
table ce que vous voulez le pari est la
seule ville et la france est le seul
pays au monde
vous pouvez voir dans la culture du
monde entier le sol même en amérique
nord l'angleterre ça n'existe pas ça
donc je suis violemment pour ouvrir et
là je vais simplement vous expliquer sur
cette phrase à jouer je m'explique je
m'explique d'autant plus
facilement qu'à l'époque on nous a fait
comprendre je ne suis pas le seul à
m'être exprimée et probablement pas de
cette manière là je me souviens de
suzanne flon francine bergé parce qu'on
nous a expliqué qu'on était xénophobe et
qu'après tout alors mais aussi on
appellera loin des thèses du front
national soit qu'on a répondu qu'on
était les programmes en avoir créé des
auteurs étrangers
d'accord je vous remercie beaucoup donc
je rappelle le titre de votre pièce
c'est le mari la femme et l'amant de
sacha guitry au théâtre des variétés à
partir du 16 janvier merci beaucoup et
on sera là
bah oui qu'est ce que vous voulez venez
à plus je reçois maintenant franz
olivier giesbert pour la parution chez
grasset de son roman le sur dieu sur
fond de guerre de religion une épopée
métaphysique tout au long de laquelle un
seigneur mystique et tout puissant agit
comme le tout puissant en soulageant
malades mendiants et impuissant bref
giesbert signe un roman d'yves un bon
soir lorsque les gens vont pas le croire
mais c'est vrai alors on vous appelle
fog comme ppda bhl vge dsk mais c'est
vrai c'est mes parents m'ont appelé
france pour le cas où il restait aux
états unis parce que je suis né aux
états unis d'un père américain et puis
ils ont mis à tirer les qu'olivier pour
le cahier entrerait en france et au bout
de trois ans ils sont entrés en france
ils ont décidé de m'appeler olivier ça
marchait bien entendu je veux qu'on
m'appelle france
mais pour faire français quand même je
gardais franz olivier aimont relance a
fait 35 giesbert ce qui fait feu sacré
fox and away c'est ça ma table de
baptême et afoc puisse acheter
ça fera un autre de romancier oui alors
est ce personnage evans hubert était et
aegean et votre mère normande est
d'ailleurs après par la suite j'ai été
correspondant du nouvel obs aux états
unis voilà c'est le disque de stone et
charden made in normandie vous
connaissez oui ce métier normandie bien
sûr c'est moi alors directeur des
rédactions du figaro du figaro magazine
vous avez fait pas mal décès sur chirac
et mitterrand qui ont été récemment aux
deux personnages de prédilection mille
pages en 25 ans sur ces deux êtres
et puis alors chirac juste un mot
aujourd'hui chirac
face la suite la fin oui ça continue ça
va moi je crois qu'un homme politique
est jamais mort 1 3l son tiraillement
vous pensez que chirac peut encore s'en
sortir quand vous voyez midi en réalité
dont il est revenu tout et je crois que
chirac
tant qu'il aura là l'énergie le feu
intérieur et je crois qu'il l'a toujours
il arrivera tout voire mondiale non
politique ces gens là ne meurent pas
voyons jamais est temps qu'ils ont la
flamme
tant qu'ils sont vivants et publié s'est
alors je monte lesueur dieu donc le
roman qui vous qui vous amène ici
aujourd'hui c'est votre quatrième roman
il ya eu monsieur adrien au soleil en 82
moi on m'a dit quand j'ai dit à deux
trois copains que vous recevez on m'a
dit si tu veux tout savoir de franz
olivier giesbert les messieurs adrien
l'affreux chez grasset un roman
autobiographique voilà les gels les
apôtres réussi lafreux chez grasset en
92 donc grand prix du roman de
l'académie avec la souys toujours chez
grasset en 95 et bien failli avoir le
goncourt
ouais je me pensais vraiment que je
l'aurais fait et l'interallié vous avez
déclaré d'ailleurs après maintenant que
j'ai eu le prix il faut que devient
écrivain alors lesueur dieu donc avant
de parler du bouquin vous écrivez depuis
l'âge de 7-8 ans donc c'est pas juste
j'écris des romans tout le temps quand
j'étais enfant j'écrivais je lui
commencé à écrire oui c'est ça va vers
7-8 ans et ça vous avez dû je sais pas
où j'ai dû j'ai dû dire ça mais c'est
vrai j'ai fait
des pièces de théâtre chanté des poèmes
et les romans j'ai commencé après dix
ans plus tôt vers 12-13 ans et j'en
faisais jusqu'à deux parents qui n'est
pas terrible qui étaient parfois très
courts et
beaucoup ont brûlé j'en suis très
content d'ailleurs alors vous êtes un
peu de chance au public ce qu'on lit
après c'est assez consternant
on a été très impressionné par max gallo
qui nous expliquait la semaine dernière
qui faisait comme les moines service
lever à 3 heures du matin il se
recoucher 20 minutes on reçoit demain
jacques attali qui lui se lève je crois
à 4 heures du matin et vous vous écrivez
à partir de 5 heures du matin et ça file
des complexes à tout le monde ça tous
les gens qui ont tendance à me dise
après tu rencontres ces mecs là comment
ils font pour se lever à 5 heures vous
l'avez toujours très très tôt comme ça
ouais enfin il y apprend le chien peut
se souvenir que je ne dors pas beaucoup
mais j'ai remarqué aussi quand même les
périodes où j'écris je dors beaucoup moi
si je me lève avec une idée avec la
turquie en vue d'écrire vite voix
intérieure vous dites souvent que quand
vous écrivez assez vite on cherche la
voile avec elle dès qu'elle vient il
faut que j'écrive très jeune garçon
après le risque de disparaître quand
elle disparaît ne revient pas avant
longtemps et parfois vous êtes obligés
d'arrêter le livre il reste encore une
radio vous captez j'ai quelques romans
au plan comme ça s'est arrêté
en tous les cas si honda s'étaler
jusqu'au bout ce qui est très
intéressant c'est que c'est un
serial-killer donc un serial killer qui
se passe en 1545
c'est une c'est une bonne idée comme l'a
souhaité un thriller rural quoi oui sauf
dhorasoo ne savais pas qu'il y avait qui
avait tué là il ya quand même absorbe
oui si on peut dire c'est un roman
policier
oui on attend on attend la fin pour
savoir qui est le serial-killer crime et
crime et châtiment aussi au lycée toutes
proportions gardées
je veux dire l'idée n'était pas de faire
un roman policier bien entendu l'idée
c'était de raconter une époque de
raconter un personnage moi j'ai besoin
de d'habiter
dans le roman de décrire ce que je vois
et donc j'ai vu cette histoire j'ai vu
ce personnage a commencé à raconter
l'histoire et puis il se trouve qu'il ya
eu des crimes bien une suite de crimes
et à la fin il a bien fallu trouver le
coupable ou non coupable
j'ai trouvé vraiment oui mais moi non
plus je n'attendais pas c'est à dire de
30 kg avant la fin j'avais toujours pas
qu'avec le monde est sectionnée
d'ailleurs même tout le monde ça va
changer soupçonne un juif parce que j'ai
moi aussi vous seriez vous prête le juif
alors le cadre c'est le luberon alors
c'est très rigolo parce que celui bairon
quand comber luberon on parlerait enfin
les gens du coin et n'aime pas du tout
le bon ordre sous luberon ça sonne mieux
oui cette région évidemment où la gauche
caviar prend ses quartiers d'été de
grands week-ends du mois de mai on a du
mal à imaginer que ça a été le lieu d'un
de tels massacres au moment de moment où
les rires éradication de l'hérésie
vaudoise
voilà les vaudois sont des
hérétique entre guillemets parce que son
pote très erratiques en fait très
intéressant il participe à un mouvement
de contestation générale 10 ans ou des
mouvements se mettaient à contester
l'ordre social au nom du christ il ya eu
les bogomil les pattes alors que eux ils
arrivent ils arrivent au fond ils vont à
la messe
il conteste pas fondamentalement
l'église ils peuvent ils ont ils se
confient ils participent la plupart des
rites mais ils sont vos droits et
surtout il ya quelque chose
espèce de contestation fondamentale chez
eux ils disent il faut lire la bible
oui il faut lire le nouveau testament il
faut lire l'évangile alors c'est vrai
que quand on a lu l'évangile et qu'on
lisse et paroles mais finalement lui bon
ben il ya un problème pour l'église de
l'époque qui ne veut pas que les fidèles
mise
la bible en français c'est pour ça que
la bible à l'époque et on atteint en
gros ils veulent vivre comme des appeaux
doigt ils veulent vivre comme dans
l'église des premiers temps sont
départagées partageons métaphysique
ils sont habillés pauvrement et noir de
enfin ils sont capables sont alors
françois 1er dont jacques lang nous a
décrit ici même la douceur angevine
c'est quand même un peu plus le sujet à
partir de 15h35 l affaire des placards
c'est bien qu'il ya des protestants qui
commence à qui kohl des placards juin
enfin des affiches d'époque jusque sur
la porte de la chambre de passe en
premier dans son château et il vient un
peu fou à ce moment là et il vient très
répressif et sur la grosse vers la
vérole ça je raconte lui parce qu'on
vous dit il a la grosse tête et la
paroisse du roi oui oui les bouffées
partout puisqu'il avait là il avait un
fils d'une fistule régulièrement dans le
nez il a dit lui-même qu'il avait
sur le génitoires jeu mais ne se
ressemblent pas la verra la murray mania
la vérole bon il
il a traîné cette veyron très longtemps
et c'est vrai qu'à la longue si je crois
que ça finissait par taper un peu sur le
dos alors c'est donc il envoie ses
troupes avec celle du pape de l'époque
l'autre la fois contre les vaudois pour
l'extermination c'est ce qu'on demande
aux troupes vidéo c'est ce qu'ils font
vias sur dieu au milieu jeu en dieu de
viguery m chirurgien de son état qui qui
se trouve là pendant ces massacres
alors c'est très à l'écouté médecine
parce que lui on le voit il s'essaie à
un poste d'observation formidables m
chirurgie à parce qu'on voit soigner les
gens avec les méthodes de l'époque alors
le meilleur médicament séduit le bouilli
sait quelque chose
grattez les rations sont l'une d'elles
une bouillie c
effectivement un gros must en avait
partout le vin aussi les [ __ ] des cas
une petite blessure c'est vrai qu'on a
tendance à mettre vite il fait beaucoup
de touchers vaginaux aussi alors d'abord
parce que sérieux ce délice poids oui
d'accord mais quand vous y prenez un
malin plaisir parce que d'abord le
serial killer évidemment il faut dire
qu'ils tuent les vierges et qu'il rate
le foie
et puis de temps en temps il les viols
lors tous les tubes sheva gignon là
franchement on n'y avait pas de ma mort
c'est le cas de veolia
c'est que il y a tout un langage de
l'époque moi c'est un roman qui se passe
dans une dans une période de l'histoire
française extrêmement noir
bon il y en aura d'autres on en a
d'autres d'ailleurs un peu partout dans
le monde je veux pas faire une métaphore
m'enfin c'est bon en même temps j'essaye
de mettre de l'humour
l'humour je peux mettre par les maux de
l'époque par les histoires aussi par un
ton dieu pour parler du sexe masculin
les vivants qui pille on languit le mât
touré
les sexes féminins et je trouve que là
dessus c'est totalement politique je ne
sais pas c'est dommage qu'on l'ait
abandonné le cas les districts c'est un
peu compliqué mais le jardin l'abricot
pensant que ça maintenant on joue là
parce que je vous en parle
bien sûr que j'ai fait ma carrière
maintenant avant qu'on se connaisse
alors ce genre je rends dieu de la
viguerie il est pas comme les autres
parce que lui la fin voyage de l'autre
côté de la terre pour aller chercher des
cocons de soie
je le cite parce que c'est pour le
compte d'un type savez le melkior de
belle-mère l'oms et des noms formidable
faire le baron d'oppède ça faisait déjà
très jolie n'ont rien seul personnage
vraiment qui a existé à partir du gimssi
aussi l'évêque de cavaillon il ya jean
maynier d'oppède le baron de paix ils
étaient ils étaient là et c'est le
personnage qui a massacré les vaudois
alors lui et revenez les autres nous
mettons à l'immense inventé mais des
noms de l'époque
ouais c'est à dire que thomas non je les
sens en valais il s'appelle thomas
poursuit alors lui les revenus donc de
l'autre côté de la terre avec une vision
un petit peu sa critique de la religion
pour le moins et il est un petit peu ça
m'a fait penser à un bouquin je pas si
vous l'avez sûrement lui d'ailleurs
qu'on lisait beaucoup dans les années 70
c'était les grands initiés de chauray et
tout à l'époque on était baba on lisait
tous ce bouquin parce que nous expliquer
que toutes les religions stable c'était
à peu près la même chose quoi et quand
fête dieu communiquer à travers
différents prophète c'est tout à fait
l'esprit du livre disent ah oui entre
entre nous je
j'enfile des perles parce que je le dis
à ma façon enfin il ya tellement il ya
d'ailleurs des prophètes eux mêmes
qu'ils ont dû regarder ce cas ce qu'a
dit mme annie madness si il est arrivé
au 3e siècle après jésus-christ fils a
dit voilà bon moi je suis le nouveau
prophète avant il ya eu les yeux il ya
eu bouddha il ya eu à bram et moi je
suis un peu la synthèse bon et je crois
que c'est une constante de l'histoire
d'humanité ces religions se font la
guerre dans ce ressemble tout à fait
venir incroyable sur regarder les dix
commandements delà du cas tony sylva du
christianisme vous y retrouver dans le
bouddhisme les mêmes pratiquement être
les mêmes mots pour trouver des mots
hindou dans le dans la bible c'est à
dire que je trouve ce système qui
consiste à croire que une religion
supérieur est absurde parce que je crois
car au fond il ya la même inspiration
voilà et ça c'est tout ce que pense
votre votre héros qui lui a de
l'expérience
on s'est peut-être un peu avec mon vieux
fond chrétien mais il faut élargir
alors donc je rappelle le titre du livre
lesueur dieu chez grasset voilà alors
vous finalement c'est un anniversaire un
petit peu aujourd'hui parce qu'il ya
trente ans vous travaillez il ya trente
ans en 1968 vous rentriez à paris
normandie
ou votre grand-père était actionnaire
faut dire ça quand même tu as eu des
imprimeurs et donc après alors fait une
carrière formidable c'est vrai vous
devez pas dormir beaucoup à 22 ans vous
rentrez voulais pas rester à paris
normandie pourquoi ce que vous semblez
trop facile parce que je voulais pas
être fils à grand papa comme on dit
c'était je voulais faire mes preuves à
paris et puis ensuite retourné à we are
we parce que j'aime beaucoup le nombre
d'heures à 22 ans pigiste nouvel
observateur 32 ans déjà donc dix ans
après chef du service politique à 36 ans
directeur de la rédaction et donc vingt
ans après avoir commencé à travailler en
88 il ya donc dix ans de maintenant vous
partez vous partez au figaro là ça a été
quand même le plus grand retournement de
veste de l'histoire de la presse
française une autre avant qu'elle ait
deux heures le patron de l'umps qui
devient le patron du figaro c'est vrai
que c'est assez triste
s'ils voulaient que ça fait d'avoir
autant d'histoires en a beaucoup que ça
c'est le côté malades de la société
médiatique française c'est à dire qui à
force de regarder son nombril d'attraper
un terrible torticolis parce que cette
affaire-là n'est pas très intéressantes
et parfois mental c'est à dire que moi
j'étais au nouvel observateur où j'étais
très heureuse
bonjour âge avait des petits problèmes
disons freudien ou avec jean daniel j'en
ai tué oui c'est clair je ne pilote pas
mettre fin dès que c'était c'était
parfois une section vip mais ça marchait
bien le journal marché très bien je
crois que j'avais contribue quand même à
le redresser sacrément puisqu'il était
quand même pas en été un petit aux états
quand j'avais été nommé à la direction
des rédactions est bon tout ça fait que
il a fallu que je parte un moment donné
je pense qu'il fallait il fallait que je
parte mais j'ai pris au figaro c'est ça
qui a choqué les gens je suis allé
j'étais disons un peu la droite du
nouvel observateur c'est à la gauche du
figaro l'accélération weir difficile
mais mais mais c'est une caricature un
peu quand on dit ça mais c'est pas faux
c'est à dire que les les journaux ne
sont pas des partis politiques depuis
longtemps chacun a des valeurs
ce qu'on peut dire c'est pour ça
l'histoire de retournement de veste
comme tous les journalistes
oui tous les bons journalistes
retournent leur veste en permanence à
dire ça va changer d'avis c'est
seulement aujourd'hui
non mais c'est de pouvoir sauter
rapidement de l'hiver aussi s'aimer si
vous voulez quand vous entrez dans un
journal vous n'entrez pas dans un parti
politique
non mais je crois que c'est ça qui est
important ici moi je garde écoutez moi
je n'ai pas changé
j'ai gardé les mêmes amis oui je crois
que c'est à peu près toujours la même
tronche soutien à l'école et à la marée
et prada oui oui vous dire quand même
pour être tout à fait précis et clair
c'est que votre mère était comme
actionnaire de paris normandie et quand
hersant a voulu racheter par rivers
menti quand m il ya eu un procès il ya
comme une
voilà ce qu'a ressenti comme ça qu'on
s'est connus oui d'accord faisait qu'un
procès la non non non mais ça fait un
peu chier c'est parce que je le voyais
de temps en temps parce qu'ils ont
essayé de négocier ils s'engueulaient
tout le temps et puis j'ai fait des
articles sur lui je les rencontre et je
suis un des rares journées ski qui s'est
laissée interview citizen ercis dans
l'ope 176 qui était ravageur contre est
absolument contraire sens mais quand
même je suis le seul journaliste
qui l'a pratiquement l'un des deux ou
trois journalistes qui ont eu une
éthique et où il a la chance ou la grâce
d'avoir unités anderson et donc les
rapports étaient plus compliquées que
cela est faux pas
vous étiez vous l'avez beaucoup absous
versant quand même parce que à l'époque
où on vous dit parler de non pas il n'a
jamais été collaborateur mais c'est
parti d'un parti qui s'appelait jeunes
feront je pense quand on vous disait
suggestions et cette histoire a pris une
émission sur antenne 2 caps l'édition
spéciale où on a démontré quand même
qu'effectivement il avait brisé quelques
vitrines de magasins juifs
et vous vous aviez dix et des fadaises
comme c'est comme était toujours assez
tolérant avec 400 noms il ressent
d'abord est quelqu'un qui gagne à être
connu c'est quelqu'un que moi j'aimais
beaucoup et
comme il sait jamais vraiment occupés
justement de la petite société
médiatique ouais et qui n'a jamais
répondu
par contre c'est vrai que temps en temps
il répondait comme ça il parlait à l'afp
il répondait mais c'est vrai qu'il n'est
jamais vraiment occupé de sa publicité
de ces relations et communications et
c'est vrai mais
moi c'est quelqu'un que j'aimais bien
j'étais très content de travailler avec
lui il m'a appris pour conclure parce
que malheureusement voyez le temps nous
pressent même sur paris première vous le
savez bien même si on est un peu plus
long que les autres quand même conclure
un moment est ce que finalement vous au
delà de l'engagement politique si vous
vous êtes surtout un dandinant vous êtes
vous êtes plus partie sens de plus pour
une posture esthétique que pour un
engagement militant vous ai jamais signé
beaucoup de pétitions ou non non je
produis de signer des pétitions mais en
même temps enfin compliqué cela parce
que là je parle de moi là on fait
vraiment du tout média avec mais ça se
termine heureusement mais mais il ya
jean edern hallier qui
un jour aller balancer des vacheries sur
moi comme d'habitude son aberration
quand même assez particulière et il
avait dit gatsby honteux c'est pas faux
je crois que c'est sûrement un côté les
gats be et donc dandy et en même temps
assez honteux aussi je suis révolté je
suis révolté je suis révoltée par ce que
je vois survoltés par la société je suis
révoltée par les europe
enfin je crois que c'est un livre
d'ailleurs ce roman la mesure du est un
roman de révolte et donc ça on est
toujours double au fond si vous voulez
le fond de ma pensée
après avoir beaucoup travaillé sur le
budget je crois que je suis schizophrène
pour écouter double c'est bien
personnage double ou iv de vie comme
cela merci en tous les cas merci
beaucoup
donc je rappelle le titre du bouquin
c'est le sieur dieu chez grasset s'est
vraiment bien je vous dis au début je
les lui parce que je vous recevrai et
puis je me suis dit c'est gagné et je le
conseille à tous nos amis merci françois
et corrections de ne rien rater de
l'inaptitude abonnez vous y mettez un
peu de bleu